es ist verblüffend die aufregung wegen
kevin kühnert nimmt einfach kein ende
was hat er dafür eine welle losgetreten
dieser freche kleine umverteiler
unglaublich ja der mann der konzerne wie
bmw vergesellschaften will und er meint
jeder deutsche soll nur noch so viel
wohnraum besitzen wie er selbst bewohnt
wie soll ich denn alle meine häuser
selber bewohnen und was sagt denn das
volk zu robin hood dies ideen enteignen
ich weiß nicht dass ihn ja dann
verhältnisse wie in der früheren ddr
wir haben uns noch nicht einverstanden
ist glaube ich das ist ein neuer top ist
nicht weiter höchst weiter
der knall koppel cubano ohne sonne war
gut sagen wir dazu eine staatlich
gelenkte volkswirtschaft kann kein
geistig gesunder mensch wohl aber ich
sage mal ein staat der nur staunend
daneben steht während immer mehr bürger
die hälfte ihres einkommens für miete
zahlen ist ja auch nicht die lösung
im übrigen hat ist juso chef nicht
bundeskanzler
ja und auch nicht staatsratsvorsitzender
das ist ja debatten über gerechtigkeit
in einem land mit neun millionen
menschen im niedriglohnsektor viele
davon mit topchancen auf altersarmut
müssen ja wohl möglich sein aber gut für
deutschlands leistungsträger ist kühnert
jetzt feindbild nummer eins da könnte
auch weil sie nicht die lottozahlen
vorlesen und die leute würden das hier
verstehen wir wollen mensch taten und
wir wollen morgen zu den mistgabeln und
fackeln greifen wir wollen
konzernzentrale stürmen wie revolution
für diese art politik stehen die jusos
ich wusste ich musste
der stall ist
selten eine so historische debatte
erlebt die bild zeitung schreibt zitat
die ddr ein land mit schießbefehl gegen
die eigenen bürger
und nun die kevin kühnert im
schützengraben und träumt vom neuen
klassenkampf verstehen sie ja wenn sie
versuchen das gebiet der brd zu
verlassen wird kevin kühnert auf sie
schießen meine damen und herren
und hier annegret kramp karrenbauer
kommt mit einem kühnen vergleich
den habe ich überhaupt nicht verstanden
ich erinnere das an jemand der mit
seinem hund spazieren geht sondern sind
dann die hundebesitzer die sagen ja aber
er will doch nur spielen kann man ja
glauben aber wenn man nachher mit tiefen
bisschen im krankenhaus liegt dann hat
man eine schmerzhafte erfahrung gemacht
was redet die frau kathi fröhlich
geraucht oder was die klasse noch mal
noch mal selbst wenn man wie ich auch
gegen verstaatlichungen ist darf man
noch nicht so tun als ob unsere art
kapitalismus 100 prozent suzuki wäre man
könnte warum gesponnen zum beispiel
mieten staatlich deckeln einkünfte aus
kapitalerträgen die arbeit will sich der
weg ist die spd mal ernsthaft mit künast
esel auseinandersetzen
ach ja komisch das dachte ich mir ja ist
ja gerade wahlkampf da sind system den
button natürlich kassen gibt dann ruft
wieder gerd schröder bei der name ist an
und so springt ja obwohl ich stelle euch
das gas ab
wieder andere genossen klingen als wäre
künert ein verhaltens auffälliges
problemkind wir freuen uns über eine
politisierte jugend die solche
grundsätzlichen debatten auch anstößt
aber diejenigen die dann die praktische
politik am ende umsetzen müssen die
müssen sich natürlich mit den konkreten
vorschlägen auseinandersetzen und das
tun wir ja wir haben mit dem kevin
geredet er hat jetzt drei wochen netflix
verboten was ist das denn für ein
herablassender mama tonfall der typ ist
29 und kein teenager jetzt am kiosk mit
allen hughes von seinem lieblings
keppeln dem kevin diese woche findet den
perfekten rudi für jede jahreszeit und
worum man ihn nie waschen darf außerdem
der kevin stark schnitt diese woche mit
den ersten drei flusen aus für uns
sieben clubs tat doktor sommer klärt auf
kann ich vom kommunismus schwanger
werden und hilfe mein mitglied hängt
viel zu weit links kevin für teenager ab
ein wahnsinn
völlig ins leiste debatte
und speziell die sozi reaktion aus der
eigenen partei die sind wirklich absurd
der präsident des spd wirtschaftsforums
hat ja sogar den parteiausschluss
gefordert wenn es sarrazin ist noch drin
aber gehört soll raus wir schalten wir
live ins willy-brandt-haus denn dort
beginnt genau jetzt eine pressekonferenz
der spd disziplinar kommission unter der
leitung der genossen batterie niehaus
wir hören mal nein so ich denke wir
können anfangen ruhe bitte zu beginn
möchte ich eine kurze erklärung des spd
präsidiums zur causa kühnert verlesen
die sozialdemokratische partei
deutschlands stellt klar sollte durch
die äußerungen des herrn kühnert der
eindruck entstanden sein
die spd wolle an den bestehenden
verhältnissen grundsätzlich irgendetwas
ändern oder sei gar eine linke partei
dann tut uns das von herzen leid
selbstverständlich sind wir uns unserer
primären aufgabe in deutschland immer
bewusst angela merkel so lange wie
möglich im amt zu halten
vielen dank der gitarrist auch deshalb
einig so wir sind genauso bestürzt wie
sie meine damen und herren
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch der kevin
war leider immer ein schwieriges kind
schon im grundschulalter hat er nichts
mehr gelebt als andere kinder zu
enteignen
er hat sogar jeden tag den bmw seiner
lehrerin vergesellschaftet
[Musik]
man hätte es wissen können
kevin kühnert hat der spd schweren
schaden zugefügt deswegen schließen wir
uns ausdrücklich der kritik des genossen
sigmar gabriel an
der ex spd vorsitzende wirft dem juso
chef methoden die bei donald trump vor
wie dem us präsidenten seien auch
kühnert nur der mediale effekt und das
eigene ego wichtig ich wiederhole das
nochmal weil es ja doch erstmal komisch
klingt sigmar gabriel also der sigmar
gabriel findet dass kevin kühnert ein
medien geiler egomane ist gibt es sonst
noch fragen von presseseite ja ich hätte
eine steht nicht im aktuellen spd
grundsatzprogramm der satz der
demokratische sozialismus bleibt für uns
die vision einer freien und
solidarischen gesellschaft jetzt sonst
noch fragen nicht der fall
gut der disziplinarausschuss der spd
gibt bekannt als gegengewicht zu den
aufmüpfigen jusos gründet sich heute
eine neue organisation die alten
sozialdemokraten in der spd kurz die
asis egal
außerdem wird folgende strafe gegen
kevin kühnert verhängt er schreibt jetzt
hier vor den augen der weltpresse 500
mal an die tafel
ich soll keine eigenen ideen mehr haben
der lukom mach weiter sind noch 492 und
in schönschrift kevin valerie niehaus
meine damen und herren
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag wünschen überall
lassen ihre techniken liegen und hier
last jetzt dass selbst ein beschissenes
autobahn
[Musik]